[Musique]
Athènes berceau de la civilisation
européenne
lieu de naissance de la démocratie et de
la philosophie
après l'Egypte quoi de plus naturel que
de poursuivre mon exploration par la
Grèce ce pays a régné sur le bassin
méditerranéen durant des siècles et
lorsqu'on parle de philosophie l'image
du sage grec avec sa longue barbe nous
vient immédiatement à l'esprit
Socrate Platon Aristote mais aussi
Pythagore Thalès ou Épicure des
personnages qui nous sont familiers même
si nous ne connaissons pas précisément
le contenu de leur doctrine on sait que
la Grèce a entretenue des liens
culturels avec l’égypte d'où le nom
donné à la ville égyptienne de Thèbes
baptisé ainsi par les Grecs parce
qu'elle leur appelait leur cité du même
nom
sur le plan mythologique de nombreuses
divinités grecques empruntent les
attributs du panthéon égyptien
Hermès équivalent grec du dieu Thot Zeus
associé à la figure Damon et lorsque
Platon parle du voyage de l'âme après la
mort il dit lui-même que cette
conception provient des savoirs d'Egypte
mais la Grèce ce sont aussi ces sites
archéologiques ces temples ces monuments
ces colonnes qui exercèrent une
influence considérable sur l'art
européen
toute notre culture occidentale porte
l'empreinte des Grecs à tel point que
certains commentateurs n'ont pas hésité
à dire que la pensée européenne n'était
qu'une longue suite de note de bas de
page au dialogue de Platon
il n'en fallait pas plus pour me donner
envie de reprendre du service allez en
Grèce pour voir de mes propres yeux les
vestiges que nos lointains ancêtres y
ont laissé toucher de mes mains ces
monuments témoins de l'intelligence et
de la détermination humaine
et une fois encore je n'ai pas été déçu
du voyage
la Grèce est un pays à la croisée des
influences son alphabet un peu déroutant
de prime abord nous donne l'impression
de ne pas être tout à fait en Europe
mais sa culture de la table etc…
[Musique]
la plupart de ces sites ont été édifiés
entre le XIIIe et le cinquième siècle
avant Jésus-Christ Athènes est l'une des
cités les plus anciennes au monde avec
une fondation qui remonte à l'an - 800
lorsqu'on visite Athènes le premier site
incontournable et l'Acropole où se situe
le fameux Parthénon érigé au 5e siècle
avant Jésus-Christ en l'honneur de la
déesse Athéna le temple a été fortement
endommagé en 1687 suite à l'explosion
d'une poudrière lors d'un conflit entre
les Turcs et les Vénitiens la façade du
Parthénon est encore en cours de
restauration comme en témoigne cette
grue qui il faut bien l'admettre gâche
un peu le paysage
sur une pente de l'Acropole on trouve le
théâtre de Dionysos dieu de l'ivresse
c'est là que les Grecs se réunissaient
pour assister aux tragédies que
Nietzsche considérait comme le sommet de
l'art européen lors des Dionysies des
concours de théâtre était organisés qui
permet de révéler quelques jeunes
talents parmi lesquels et chill Sophocle
ou Euripide le théâtre faisait partie
intégrante de la vie culturelle
athénienne sa fonction n'était pas
seulement le divertissement mais aussi
la catharsis la purgation des passions
et l'apprentissage par l'exemple au pied
de l'Acropole on pourra s'arrêter devant
ce qui passe pour être la prison de
Socrate pour rappel Socrate fut condamné
à mort par le tribunal d'Athènes en 399
avant Jésus-Christ accusé d'inquiéter et
de corruption de la jeunesse il fut
enfermé pendant quelques jours dans
cette jaule en attendant sa mise à mort
par absorption de la ciguë
son ami Créton tentera de le faire
s'évader mais Socrate refusera au motif
que s'évader ce serait allé contre les
lois qui sont le fondement de la cité
cette prison ne symbolise donc pas
seulement le sort réservé aux dissidents
elle représente le sacrifice d'un homme
pour qui les idées survivent à la mort
du corps
[Applaudissements]
le deuxième jour de mon voyage je
découvrais l'ancienne Corinthe célèbre
pour son long canal offrant aux
visiteurs une vue vertigineuse Corinth
rivalisa sur le plan économique avec
Thèbes et Athènes la cité est réputée
pour ses etaïres ces prostituées éduqués
et respectées qui influençaient les
hommes d'État et inspirer les
philosophes le site archéologique de
Corinthe se compose principalement des
colonnes restantes du temple d'Apollon
dieu de la beauté si Dionysos incarne
l'ivresse la fête et la démesure Apollo
incarne la sobriété la raison et
l'équilibre pour Nietzsche la tragédie
grecque était le produit de la rencontre
entre ces deux mondes le monde chaotique
de Dionysos et le monde ordonné
d'Apollon les amateurs d'ésotérisme
yveront probablement une figuration des
deux principes à l'origine de l'univers
et le chaos
à quelques kilomètres de là on trouve la
cité préhlénique de Mycènes construite
durant l'âge de bronze et dont le mythe
raconte qu'elle aurait été le royaume
d'Agamemnon même si sa porte d'hélión a
de quoi impressionné là encore on ne
peut qu'être sensible au délabrement du
site l'histoire est passée par là et
lorsque l'histoire passe elle laissera
rarement les choses intactes en Égypte
j'ai vu des monuments dans un état de
conservation proche de la perfection
l'obélisque de Carnac les statues
géantes de Louxor ou d'Abou Simbel comme
si les anciens Égyptiens avaient quitté
les lieux la veille en Grèce je trouvais
essentiellement des ruines
lorsqu'on fait face au temple
d'Asclépios à épidor dont la façade
n'est plus constituée que de ces deux
malheureusement un sentiment de
frustration et de tristesse nous envahit
un manquablement un sentiment encore
plus prononcé lorsqu'on s'arrête à
Sparte devenu aujourd'hui une petite
ville touristique et dont il ne subsiste
de la période antique que ces quelques
blocs de pierre
je me suis interrogé sur ce sentiment
pourquoi un tel sentiment ma visite de
l'Égypte m'avait-elle rendu insensible
au charme des vestiges de la Grèce était
devenu une sorte de consommateur
culturel insatisfait se plaignant de
devoir reconstituer par son imagination
ce que l'histoire avait soustrait à son
regard
cette question a occupé mon esprit
durant tout mon séjour en Grèce la
question des ruines auquel on accorde la
valeur précisément parce qu'elles sont
des ruines mais pourquoi leur
accordons-nous cette valeur
les ruines constituent une survivance du
passé elles sont le témoignage présent
de ce qui a existé avant nous le rappel
en somme que nous ne serions pas là sans
l'histoire qui nous a précédé si on
trouve que les ruines ont du charme ce
n'est pas tant pour ce qu'elles sont que
pour ce qu'elles représentent la
résistance aux forces de l'usure et du
temps comme si c'était l'histoire dont
elles sont porteuses qui leur confère et
leur beauté
que cette question m'a le plus travaillé
là j'ai vu des colonnes dont certaines
parties avaient été reconstituées
renforçant davantage encore cette
impression que le temps détruit tout je
me suis alors posé cette question que
certains jugeront hérétiques ne
faudrait-il pas restaurer ces monuments
utilisez nos techniques modernes pour
leur redonner l'éclat et la grandeur de
leur origine au risque de leur ôter tout
authenticité on trouve normal de
restaurer des toiles de maître lorsque
celle-ci sont en voie de dépérissement
pourquoi en a-t-il autrement des sites
archéologiques
restaurer s dénaturé ou est simplement
rétablir
je m'interroge je m'interroge sur notre
rapport au passé sur notre penchant à la
mélancolie devant les vestiges des temps
anciens je me demande si avoir fait des
sites de l'antiquité de vastes musées à
ciel ouvert n'aurait pas paradoxalement
contribué à nous en éloigner comme si
nous tenions à marquer la limite entre
nous et le passé
comme si nous préférions les cercueils
au berceau
[Musique]
Adelphes où j'ai achevé ma visite
l'architecture s'intègre magnifiquement
dans le paysage qui accueille le site à
la puissance de la pierre montagneuse
vient répondre l'élévation de la pierre
maçonnée un combat entre la nature et la
culture où l'homme est contraint de
réaliser des prouesses s'il veut
rivaliser avec l'univers
ou la démonstration de force ne sert pas
seulement à faire reculer l'ennemi mais
à surpasser notre mortalité
levez la tête comme pour mieux éprouver
notre petitesse levez la tête comme pour
mieux nous rappeler qu'il fut un temps
où l'architecture n'avait pas seulement
une fonction mais une signification
c'est là que j'ai ressenti quand dépit
des ruines et des ravages du temps la
puissance de ces monuments restait
intacte ces colonnes qui s'élèvent dans
le ciel nous obligeant à plisser les
yeux tant elles côtoie le soleil demeure
une expérience sans équivalent touchez
le ciel tel semble avoir toujours été
l'ambition des hommes à travers les âges
touchez le ciel comme pour se rapprocher
des dieux sans rapprocher pour leur
ressembler comme si le destin de l'homme
était de vouloir devenir Dieu
l’épisode biblique de la tour de Babel
est un modèle du genre uni par un
langage et une volonté commune les
hommes érigentours pour atteindre le
ciel Dieu punira cette affront en
détruisant la tour et en mélangeant les
langues sans communication pas de
communion l'humanité devra recommencer
réinventer un langage commun se
réunifier pour un jour peut-être
prétendra à nouveau au titre de
divinités et quand le mythe devient
philosophie on retombe sur Platon et sa
conception de l'âme humaine l'idée que
l'âme est immortel qu'au moment de notre
mort elle quittera notre enveloppe
charnelle et qu'elle rejoindra les dieux
pour l'éternité dans le ciel des idées
j'aimerais à présent donner la parole à
Benjamin organisateur de voyage qui m'a
accompagné durant mon séjour si vous
souhaitez vous rendre en Grèce pour
visiter les sites sur lesquels je me
suis rendu je vous laisse ses
coordonnées dans la description au terme
de notre voyage j'ai demandé à Benjamin
pourquoi selon lui il fallait visiter la
Grèce lorsqu'on vit des sites antiques
grec la première ressenti que l'on a
c'est peut-être se dire ou là c'est un
petit peu foody parce que beaucoup de
choses sont au sol il reste que très peu
de vestiges qui sont érigés finalement
par contre dans un second temps une fois
qu'on prend c'est vrai que ça c'est
impératif en graisse prendre le temps
d'analyser les écritos touristiques qui
sont mis sur les sites de lire sans
guide de voyage par exemple d'écouter
son guide aussi on arrive à prendre un
petit peu plus l'ampleur des lieux
l'Acropole ce qui m'a le plus marqué ce
sont les escaliers en fait quand on
monte au sommet de l'Acropole et qu'on
arrive sur ces premiers vestiges en
marbre
massifs et où quand on voit l'état de
conservation et puis cette roche qui est
assez noble en fait j'ai pas quelque
chose qui s'opère quelque chose
d'intangible une sensation qui est assez
intéressante d'autant plus que certaines
restaurations permettent à certains
endroits précis des sites de voir quelle
taille pouvait mesurer les colonnes
notamment et essayer ensuite par une
sorte de puzzle cérébrale d'arriver à
prendre l'ampleur du monument lui-même
et c'est d'en avoir la perspective parce
que j'ai adoré amicen c'est ces énormes
blocs c'est mieux recyclopéens que l'on
peut retrouver notamment Pérou le site
d'épi d'or l'endroit d'EP d'or est
magnifique parce que dans une belle
pinède et puis on arrive et on voit d'un
coup c'est amphithéâtre qui est dans un
état conservation époustouflant l'île
didera on doit prendre ce petit bateau
pour une petite heure de trajet on se
retrouve dans ce village très attachant
petit port est vraiment très mignon les
ruelles sublimes on plaisir en fait à
déambuler en Grèce
à mon travail consiste à organiser des
voyages pour agrémenter parfois un
projet d'étapes un petit peu spéciale
moi porter en tout cas mes connaissances
sur des circuits la pratique touristique
à des gens désireux de visiter un pays
ou un autre
[Musique]
j'espère que ce bref carnet de voyage en
Grèce aura éveillé votre désir dans
savoir plus sur les origines de notre
culture et de la philosophie européenne
et pourquoi pas de vous rendre sur place
pour vivre cette expérience car ce n'est
qu'à la condition de renouer avec ses
racines que l'être humain peut espérer
déployer ses ailes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]